veremos las diferencias entre la oferta
en términos de corto plazo y largo plazo
entonces digamos que en el corto plazo
si quisiéramos que una persona de tu
pueblo el cual tiene en un honda civic
2000 ya no le gusta tanto su carro con
esa persona en un día tendrías que
gastar como algunos 2500 dólares si vas
con la siguiente persona el cual también
tiene un honda civic y a él le gusta un
poco más su carro tendrías que pagarle
un poco más a él y así seguiríamos con
esto llamaremos a esto la curva de la
oferta a corto plazo curva de la oferta
a corto plazo y esta es una curva de la
demanda acá aparece una curva de la
demanda para varias cosas en la primera
unidad la persona obtiene un beneficio
marginal alto y mientras tenemos
unidades incrementales tenemos
beneficios marginales bajos otra manera
de verlo en un precio alto la demanda de
civic honda estará bajo la cantidad
demandada será baja y en precios bajos
la cantidad demandada será alta otra
manera de mirar la curva de oferta a
corto plazo en un precio bajo la
cantidad ofertada será baja y en un
precio alto la cantidad ofertada será
alta
ahora te daré más información digamos
que este es nuestro pueblo aquí tenemos
aquí en nuestro pueblo al cual vamos a
abreviar con pepe para pueblo y tenemos
más pueblos vecinos el pueblo and el
pueblo ven el pueblo se y el pueblo
declaró
digamos que cada uno de estos pueblos
incluyendo nuestro pueblo
digamos que todos tienen un precio de
equilibrio de cinco mil dólares por cada
civic honda usado y bueno este es un
vídeo que estoy grabando en el 2012
ahorita y eso eso es aproximadamente el
costo real de un civic honda puedes ver
aquí que este es el caso para nuestro
pueblo 5000 en el precio de equilibrio y
cantidad de equilibrio aproximadamente
22 civiles al día pero dado que todos
los pueblos tienen un precio de
equilibrio de 5000 pensemos en la oferta
a largo plazo para civic sonda como será
para nuestro pueblo como será la curva
que representará eso y la razón por la
cual pienso en otros pueblos es porque
siempre habrá siempre podemos hacer
intercambios podemos mover cívicos de
onda muy fácilmente entre los pueblos
pueden estar estos pueblos simplemente a
unos cuantos kilómetros de distancia
y bueno qué pasaría si en nuestro pueblo
específicamente nuestro pueblo no
nuestros pueblos solamente en el nuestro
el precio de los cívicos de onda bajarán
a menos de cinco mil dólares estamos
pensando a largo plazo si en largo plazo
el precio bajará de los cinco mil
dólares en nuestro pueblo qué pasaría
entonces la gente va a escuchar la
noticia escucharían que pueden vender su
civic por cinco mil dólares en otros
pueblos y nadie va a creer va a querer
poner en oferta sus cívicos en nuestro
pueblo
simplemente sacarán sus cívicos a otros
pueblos lo mandan para el pueblo de para
el pueblo se porque ahí pueden obtener
más dinero por ellos entonces a largo
plazo si el precio llegara a estar algo
abajo lo que sea abajo de cinco mil la
cantidad de nuestro pueblo se
aproximaría a cero a nada a nulo cero
cívico análogo si el precio en nuestro
pueblo subiera aunque sea un poquito más
de cinco mil luego de repente las
personas en otros pueblos estarán
motivadas en lugar de vender su civic en
su pueblo por 5 mil claramente lo traer
a nuestro pueblo para venderlo entonces
si el precio se ha aumentado aunque sea
un poquito
más que los cinco mil dólares tendríamos
de repente una enorme oferta muchos
cívicos llegarían al pueblo entonces
nuestra curva de la oferta a largo plazo
se miraría
algo así algo así y bueno de hecho le
puse una pendiente hacia arriba casi no
se nota en muchos libros sólo manejan
una curva horizontal elástica y en un
recordatorio que significa elasticidad
que es perfectamente elástico con un
cambio mínimo en el precio tienes un
cambio infinito de cantidad algo es muy
elástico si un cambio mínimo en el
precio llevará un cambio grande en la
cantidad esto se está aproximando a
perfecta elasticidad casi podrías decir
que el valor absoluto de la elasticidad
está aproximando a infinito en la
elasticidad de la oferta y bueno ahora
bien esto es interesante porque ahora
podemos pensar en un experimento esta es
nuestra curva curva a corto plazo esta
de aquí y esto nuestra curva a largo
plazo que sucede a través de los días
cuando la gente se entere se dé cuenta
de que los precios en pueblos vecinos y
hay tiempo para mover los carros
traslada
de un pueblo a otro qué va a pasar
digamos que nuestro pueblo de repente la
persona más famosa acaba de intercambiar
sus rolls royce por un civic honda 2000
y está esta persona pero sí súper
contenta con su civic se anda paseando
por todo el pueblo y de repente salen
las noticias fueron en las revistas
locales esta noticia no sea que guau que
esta persona tiene un civic así que todo
el mundo en el pueblo ahora quiere un
civic porque bueno está a la moda esto
solamente está pasando nuestro pueblo no
está pasando en los otros pueblos
entonces los otros pueblos el precio de
equilibrio no ha cambiado así que no
estamos cambiando esta curva de oferta a
largo plazo y como todos quieren ahora
un honda civic las preferencias han
cambiado en cualquier precio dado más
civic serán demandados hasta ritmo la
demanda incrementará incrementará
entonces se verá así así la demanda
incrementa así que la nueva curva de
demanda se verá algo así se moverá hacia
la derecha entonces en corto plazo antes
de que los cívicos tengan tiempo de ser
trasladados aquí antes de que se enteren
las personas del nuevo precio de
equilibrio
plazo el precio de equilibrio se moverá
hacia arriba y tiene sentido porque las
personas estarán ansiosas y comprarán lo
que sea que esté en el pueblo así que el
precio de equilibrio subirá a cinco mil
quinientos dólares por la compra de un
civic y esto se cumple por lo que está
pasando en el pueblo las personas van a
querer andar a la moda se puede decir
ajá entonces bueno estarán dispuestos a
pagar por un civic van a estar
dispuestos a pagar por un civil pero
pero pero qué va a pasar qué pasará a
largo plazo que pasar a las personas en
pueblos vecinos se van a enterar de que
pueden vender sus cívicos no por cinco
mil dólares sino por cinco mil
quinientos porque por alguna extraña
razón se ha vuelto un carro muy a la
moda en este pueblo así que a largo
plazo el precio se regresará a donde la
nueva curva de la demanda se intersecta
con la curva de la oferta a largo plazo
entonces a largo plazo se moverá a este
punto de aquí a la curva de la oferta a
largo plazo a largo plazo el precio era
cinco mil dólares y la cantidad vendida
será más alta y eso hace completamente
totalmente sentido ahora es un carro muy
lujoso en este pueblo entonces las
personas para querer importarlo a este
pueblo no está a la moda en otros
pueblos así que las personas van a
querer importarlo a este pueblo